and it is a chopped Christmas at Tobin
Auto Group the sponsors of this segment
they've teamed up with here with us here
at Channel 8 for the great toy drive and
I stopped by to get an update
the great toy drive is underway we're
going till December 16th and the
community is showing out here at the
Tobin dealerships shop yeah we're
filling up boxes and we appreciate
everybody that's come out and dropped
off unwrapped toys for the kiddos and
there's no time where a kid should wake
up on Christmas without having unwrapped
toys have that fun of the excitement of
what was brought what's under the tree
so we love it and we're here to support
the shade tree and what they're doing
for families in need at this time
absolutely now you know what kind of
toys you said unwrapped toys just kind
of give everybody the rules on what they
can bring to your boxes bring toys for
young children for boys for girls and
gift cards for teenagers are really good
you know so that way teens can go out
and get something that they feel is cool
and that fits their personality we feel
like that makes a lot of sense so but
whatever you want to drop off for these
kiddos is so appreciated and we're going
to fill up fans so we can make sure that
we fuel this and take care of the shade
tree at this time absolutely now you
know you told us about you know the
kiddos and the teens but I think you
guys couple gifts here for adults too
let's talk about what's here out at the
dealership well you know we get things
dropped off you know so there's all
kinds of things we got we got some baby
dolls we got some TVs we got some
PlayStations it's whatever you want to
bring you know we want to make sure that
there's some fun stuff for kids to open
up on the on Christmas and and just make
it fun for the shade tree now chop I was
talking about the cars on a lot what you
got here from Tobin you know you know we
got some whips you know we got some
whips you know we got a little couple
may box in the background over here
that's on my Christmas list so I figured
Veronica you just came in you said I
said what do you want and then you said
this Maybach I figured you got good
taste we should put it together I like
that I like that okay now tell everybody
how they can come visit you and which
which dealerships are involved all right
so we're right now at Tobin EV which is
Tobin electric vehicles and Tobin off
Romeo Fiat we got a whole bunch going on
at this complex and then right next door
we have Tobin Kia here in the Auto Mall
and then we have Tobin Dodge Ram
Superstore right around the corner in
the Auto Mall so we got a whole bunch of
locations where you can drop off your
gifts and we're ready and ready to put
them in the box and get them to the kids
thank you so much for everything you're
doing here chop for what your family
your team is doing everybody come on
down Tobin through this December 16th
for the great toy drive
the eight news now great toy drive is in
full swing as you can see we're
collecting toys and gift cards to
benefit the shade tree you can drop
donations off at any Tobin dealership
around the valley until next Friday
December 16